so
um i had a question
yes can i have my money now
thank you
all right paradise hi paradise uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally um georgia georgia
tell me about your uh childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
um i had both my parents my stepdad came
in
when i was like two
how would you describe your childhood um
all right um abusive
a lot going on what kind of abuse sexual
abuse
um so my parents getting beat up my mom
getting beat up so
yeah the sexual abuse came from who
um my family on my stepfather's side
okay how old were you um
like eight
i remember having dreams but i don't um
i remember having like dreams of them
touching me but
then it was never a dream so yeah
they're real yeah
how would you describe your childhood in
general like was it a good experience or
was it
um yeah
kinda it was like a lot more money
i'm sorry i said yeah kind of
it was okay i made a lot of money when i
was a kid
doing what prostituting oh really what
age did you start
um like ten how did you start at ten
um i ran away went to a group home
i was in sacramento at the time and then
yeah i ran away and ran straight to a
camp
tim yeah turned you out at 10 years old
wow this was in l.a
this was in los angeles you remember
your first time your first trick
at 10 years old i don't remember my
first trick but
yeah kind of not my very first no
but but guys picking up a 10 year old
girl yeah i didn't mean i didn't like
10 well i looked at like a kid probably
but that's what man like
little girls back then [ __ ] it's pretty
crazy
yeah and you were making good money
i was making a lot of money lots of
money
how much money does the 10 year old girl
make working as a prostitute
um i was making thousands thousands
uh yeah i'm making a lot of money when i
was a kid
yeah and you'd give it all the them huh
you gave it all to your pimp
i did i did not know better back then
did you ever see it did you ever see any
of that money
no well no no
that's always the case it's always the
case nobody ever says oh yeah i made a
bunch of money
that's crazy yeah how long were you with
him
um my first folks i was with him for
like
not that long because he was abusive so
i ran away fast
and you went to another one or did you
get away um
yeah i went to another one and then i
was with him for like
two years um i actually told him i was
like
18. i was only like 11
12 then when i met the second one and
yeah we was going everywhere getting a
lot of money but i never seen none of
that money though
yeah none of the girls ever do yeah see
you're traveling with him yeah but we
was in l.a for a long time we never
really traveled like that
um that was a long time ago so we never
really checked
travel like that that was so big was
making a lot of money
fig long beach boulevard
yeah how old are you now i'm 29 i'm 29
yeah still young yes
and today you're working without a pimp
or with a family
without yeah
how has the game changed over the years
you've been doing it um
even though you're young you've been
doing it for a couple decades almost
yeah um it changed a lot
actually it's way different um
what ways oh you got crackheads on the
streets now
selling lesser than what it is the
tricks are high right
yeah a lot of tricks are high and the
pimp's
not pimps they're tricking too and like
it's just
it's way different you get your gang
members very often now too
how the pimps are gang members now very
often yeah
are the pants is tricky either one
really
yeah yeah that's crazy
yeah i've heard that a lot too no one
wants to admit it
yeah i've heard that do you have kids
i have twins you have twins and you're
raising them
um no yeah no
where are they my baby father ran off
with them and i haven't seen them in
about
four years or something five years it's
got to be hard right
yeah that's the worst part
yeah i haven't changed something
yeah are drugs a part of your life
um a little no not really
um i smoke weed yeah i used to do coke
back then
yeah do you have to do you find getting
drunk or high helps
did this kind of work yes you always
have to say
you don't want to stay sober you know
yeah it'd be hard to do this sober
yes yeah
[Music]
so tell me about the guys that pick you
up now are they
excuse me somebody about the kind of
guys that will pick you up
um good guys bad guys crazy guys
had guys tried to kill me um
yeah take their money back and [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that um
have some pretty good guys but yeah
why are you looking at me like that no
i'm just i'm just listening to your
answers
do you ever hope for one of these guys
to like
take you away and yeah but ain't none of
these [ __ ] gonna do that i don't even
know
uplift the [ __ ] and take her away and
you know
pull a pretty pretty woman on you yeah
yeah i get that
i would not be here for sure i'm gone
but ain't nobody doing that these days
pimps tricks nobody so
yeah hydro for yourself does this kind
of work get to you emotionally does it
get
does this kind of work get to you
emotionally you get depressed or angry
or anything yeah
all the above and mostly because i miss
my
babies you know yeah without them i'm
not uh
i just don't i don't know you're not
complete
yeah it will never be the same without
them so you know
i try to deal with it as best as i can
but yeah have you been in love before
have you been
in love before yeah i've been in love
like three times four times
never get left back though um
yeah it's just way deeper now it is
why are you looking at me i'm i'm
thinking about my next question
well yeah horn is way way different now
you can't even walk down the street um
without somebody coming up to you twenty
dollars
forty dollars like six dollars like [ __ ]
all that
but yeah are you making are you making
less money now than you did
10 years ago um
yeah but i got still gets money though i
guess i still give money you tell me i
just
i believe yeah down there like i got a
pimp
are you saving money am i saving money
no
no why are you know that very few of the
girls are saving money
very few of the girls that are making a
thousand a night or saving money
yeah are they not making a thousand a
night i mean
yes i'm more yeah
i think some of the girls are making
quite a bit more than that
yeah i mean ryan used to make thousands
a night like literally it was a good old
days
what's the hardest part of this
lifestyle for you
um
i don't know surviving
i i would think it's it's got to be very
difficult to have everybody
out there kind of everyone's out there
up to no good you know the other girls
are
you know they're competitive and
everybody's doing something illegal
right yes from the from the tricks to
the pimps to the
even the cops are sometimes doing things
that are
not by the book right so it's like it
just gets very difficult to
keep a clear head when when everybody is
up to
something whether it's getting high or
stealing your money or doing something
um true it's got to be hard right
sure i'm talking as if i'm working the
streets
i'm just i'm the only reason i say that
is i've talked to so many girls now and
they're all telling me these
these stories and i would just think
it's got to be very difficult to
to go through that every night yeah
what do you think most people that don't
do this kind of work
don't understand about girls that work
as prostitutes
it's just never um they're never
understanding
um that's normal this um
is a whole nother different world like
so
yeah you got to be in it to to refill it
i guess
what mistakes have you learned from over
the years
um i can't even answer that question
came and asked that question a lot of
mistakes though
but like getting into a car that the car
door doesn't open from the inside
that kind of stuff yeah that happened to
me before
that's crazy yeah it's just very
dangerous for us
do you think you're addicted to this
this life i am
i am what do you get addicted to is it
the fast money is it is it just
um how easy it is it's got to be hard at
first i mean yeah
it's i mean it's easy and it's hard like
um the money uh i don't know it's just a
bad addiction
it's a really bad addiction um
it'd be hard for you to go get a square
job right
yeah well not necessarily
but yeah it's just me so much faster to
do it how i do it
do you like it i'm not content though
but i am
yeah um there's something about it you
probably like right
it got to be if i'm still doing it you
know
i'm just having attention from from men
that you like
no no no
maybe maybe
i don't know i was working the streets
for almost 20 years changed you
um your intuition's got to be heightened
right
yeah um
i'm sorry i'll get out of the emotional
[ __ ] it's ah
i don't know street smart
yeah you got to be street smart after
doing this for
18 19 years yeah
do you just stand back and look at this
and go man this is a crazy
life i've covered up carved out for
myself
all the time like i could every day
anything in the world but
yeah instead i became a prostitute did
you have dreams when you were a young
girl of doing something different
yeah what you want to do
um be a doctor you know the normal
lawyer mama's girl i ended up being
totally different opposite
like i was always a prostitute but i was
always like the tomboyish like
um the time boys didn't come to like i
got older though like you don't
so it's just i don't know
it's different do you think that sexual
abuse when you were young kind of
hopefully open the door to this yes
of course that was
yeah kind of but i just think me running
away is what
i should have just stayed my eyes at
home you hadn't run away you wouldn't
have met the pimp
right right so i put myself but
you think doing this kind of work has
changed the way you see men
um yes
yeah in what ways do you respect men
less
um i don't respect man less i just
you know i just been through a lot with
man so
uh i still treat me i'm like a man
though
so what advice would you give to a young
girl
who's thinking about doing this kind of
work to just stay at home and
focus on what you need to focus on is
not the life
you know to live because i wouldn't want
my daughters doing it i have daughters
and
i didn't even think about that to now
like you know so i wouldn't want my
babies to do it i wouldn't want them
to be out here in the streets
prostituting um it's
it's a lifestyle but only for that time
being it's nothing
good about it like for me but the fast
money that's it
it's dangerous it's very dangerous you
get asked to do crazy stuff
yes no condoms stuff like that um
yeah but i'm not doing the abdominal
condom
but yeah
where do you think you'll be in five
years you think you'll still be doing it
no how not
what do you think would get you to stop
um
another person that's just not in his
lifestyle like you know
a square yeah
getting a real job something like that
getting my kids back
yep what's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life
put yourself first yeah i don't put
others before you
i always push yourself first and i'm
still working on that now
so yeah
all right paradise thank you so much for
sharing your story okay thank you
thank you very much